Now I want to read you a story.
All right,
so let me give you a little background
to this story.
This story popped into my head in one
chunk,
like complete,
which I thought was kind of interesting,
but it was also a story that emerged in
solution to a problem I'd been thinking
about for a long time because I was
dealing with this guy who didn't want to
grow up.
So he's caught in a kind of Peter Pan
Situation and Peter Pan Pan means
everything.
Hey,
pan,
like pantheistic and Peter Pan is a
child who won't grow up.
Now he's magical.
Well,
okay,
fine.
Children live in a magical world,
right?
They're rife with possibility.
He's magical.
He doesn't want to grow up.
So he lives in Neverland with the lost
boys.
Neverland doesn't really exist in the
lost boys are obviously boys who haven't
managed to establish some mode of big
and he's in constant battle with Captain
Hook and captain hook's a tyrant,
right?
A pirate,
a negative manifestation of the negative
archetype of social order.
And Captain Kirk is always fighting
Peter Pan Because Peter Pan Represents
childhood and vulnerability and he
doesn't want to be vulnerable,
so they're locked in this sort of
eternal battle and lots of people,
I think more commonly men but not
necessarily get caught in this Peter Pan
Problem.
So I was dealing with
person who was caught in this situation,
didn't want to grow up,
wouldn't sacrifice childhood.
And so this story popped into my head.
It's called Cock-a-doodle-doo.
Once upon a time there was a man who had
a long,
hard journey ahead of him.
He was trudging along the way over
boulders and through brushes when he saw
a little shiny known with big white
teeth in the block to pay sitting by the
side of the road,
he was drumming on a log with two white
bones and humming oddly to himself.
A little gnome said,
John,
why work so hard?
Why I walked so fast?
Who knows if you'll ever get there?
Anyway,
come over here.
I have something to show you.
So John Walked off the road.
He was sick of walking anyway because
people kept throwing sticks and stones.
Adam little gnome said,
I have a shiny red jewel that I would
like to sell you cheap.
Here it is,
and for beneath his cloak he pulled the
biggest ruby that the man I'd ever seen.
It must've weighed 100 pounds and it's
shine like the sun.
The gnome said,
do you like it?
It's an enchanted stone.
What will you offer me for it?
And the man said,
I don't have much,
much money,
but I'll give you everything I have the
no look displeased.
So John added,
or I could pay some more monthly.
So the GNOME excepted.
Fair enough.
Buy Now.
Pay later.
Sounds good for me.
I'm all for the installment plan.
So the man gave him all his money and
promise to pay the rest.
Later,
and the gnome walk back into the Bush by
the road,
clacking his teeth and giggling and
twitching.
The more of the man thought about this
ruby and the great deal he got,
the happier he became.
He started back on the road with a light
heart,
but soon discovered that he couldn't
make much progress because 100 pounds
was a lot to carry.
He said to himself,
why continue anyways,
I have what I want.
I'll just stand here holding my ruby and
when people walk by they can see how
well I've already done,
so he stopped a little while.
One of his little while later,
one of his friends came along,
so I'm standing there,
he's fair,
and said,
John,
why don't you come along with me?
I've just opened a new business and I
could really use some help.
Come along quick.
It will be opening soon.
Joe,
and thought that sounded good,
but his friend was in a hurry besides
couldn't even see the ruby.
How could he speed along beside him?
Where would he put his jewel?
So he said,
thanks,
but I have to take care of my jewel.
Maybe I'll see you later.
His friend looked at him like he was
crazy,
but he was trying to get somewhere
quick,
so it just shrugged a bit and said,
okay,
John,
see you later.
Then he sped on down the road.
A little while later.
Another friend came by and he said,
John,
nice to see you.
I'm going back to school.
There are lots of wonderful things to
learn,
great things to do.
The world is full of unsolved problems.
I could use some company.
What would you like to come along?
John Thought that sounded pretty good,
but this friend who looked like he was
in a hurry.
You sorry.
Started standing beside the road,
holding the jewel was tiring and he
needed all the energy ad for that.
So he said to his friend,
thanks,
but I have to take care of my jewel.
Isn't it beautiful?
Maybe I'll see you later.
His friend looked at him like he was
crazy,
but he was trying to get somewhere
quick,
so he just shrugged and said,
hope.
Everything goes all right with you.
See you later.
Many friends came and went in the years,
went by,
the jewel got heavier and heavier,
but the man God more and more attached
to it.
The only thing was nobody seemed to
notice how beautiful it was.
People would rush by and talk about
their plans and nobody had a ruby as big
and nobody seemed likely to get A.
Ruby is big and you think that someone
might've had said something like at
least Nice Ruby,
John,
sure wish I had one like that,
but it never happened.
Then one day someone new came down the
road.
He was bent over and he was thin and his
hair was gray.
Although he didn't look that old,
he was carrying a big dirty rock
carefully in his arms and he wasn't
making much progress.
The strange figure approached and
glanced up at John and he grinned and
said,
where are you standing there so stupidly
with a big ugly rock and you're tired.
Old Hands.
You look pretty daft.
I bet you wish you had a big ruby like
the one I am carrying.
And John Thought,
this poor man is diluted.
He's carrying a rock it desire.
You have the ruby.
So he said,
excuse me sir,
but you are sadly mistaken.
I'm the one with the jewel.
I met a little known by the side of the
road and he sold it to me.
I'm still paying for it,
although not so very much.
You are carrying a rock.
The tired stranger looked annoyed.
He said,
I didn't know what game you're playing,
Mr you have a rock.
I have a jewel.
The little gnome you described sold it
to me and he said it was the only one.
I've been carrying it for 20 years and
I'll never let it go,
and John said,
but I'd been carrying mine for 20 years
too.
It can be just a rock rocker.
Jewel on and on.
They argued,
suddenly out stepped a little gnome as
if he'd never left.
Only this time he wasn't so little.
He was bigger and redder and menacing
and his laugh sounded like the rattling
of chains.
Quit arguing you too.
I've never seen a site quite so
pathetic.
You're carrying rocks,
both of you,
and if you would have ever had the sense
to put them down for a second or two,
you would have seen that,
oh well,
at least you were diligent.
I played a mean trick.
I feel bad,
so I'm going to give you what you really
deserve.
Do you want what you really deserve?
And John and the thin stranger nodded
eagerly.
Finally,
they thought you haven't seen anything
yet.
Throw down your rocks,
so John and the thin stranger obeyed.
He trucked split down the middle of when
it hit the ground outflow to river of
ravenous white worms which rushed
towards the men and devoured them whole
while they thrashed about and screamed
soon.
Nothing was left except a leg bone from
each.
The little gnome pick them up and walked
off the road.
He sat down by a hollow log and started
to drop.
He drummed any waited and he hummed and
odd little tune picture of food feeds
the whole hungry clan,
the image of good mix.
The whole healthy man.
Why walk for miles?
Why do the work?
Just smile.
The smile,
success after all is a quirk.
Life isn't real.
That's the message I give.
It's easy that way.
Plus who wants to live?
So needless to say,
the guy that I was telling this story to
never listened to it and things.
You really didn't go well for him for a
long,
long time and they really didn't go well
for him until he was willing to give up
some of the things he was carrying
along.
So he had acquired,
for example,
a number of things that he couldn't
afford and the fact that he was carrying
them right,
paying for them month after month,
man,
he couldn't afford to get an education.
It was perfectly willing to sacrifice
the possibility of getting an education
for the image of success rather than the
reverse.
Right?
And he was completely irritated at the
world because he had all these trappings
of success,
which no one he admired also admired and
he absolutely wasn't getting anywhere
and he thought that was tremendously
unfair.
But the truth of the matter was that how
do you put down what he was carrying for
even a moment?
Then he would have been able to get to
where he wanted to go.
And that's a motif that succinctly and
dramatically describes the necessity for
sacrifice.